while heads of state and government of
the 28 eu member states are set to
convene in brussels on the 24th and 25th
of october those in plenary were
critical of the summit's agenda in light
of the recent tragic migrant deaths in
the mediterranean meps argued that
economic and monetary union employment
growth and a digital economy are far
from paying a priority attempter summit
in 1999
under the presidency of finland decided
to develop finally a common migration
policy in the european union that's 15
years ago that we have taken that
decision to have a common migration
policy and here we are
here we are
with just hours to go before the
deadline for eu countries to implement
the crossbow the healthcare directive
mep francoise gostet and commissioner
tony borg reiterated the advantages of
this directive for patients across
europe the pillars of this directive are
to provide better information and in
certain circumstances better adapted
care and a definite right to
reimbursements
foreign
ensuring better protection for small
investors mep's meeting and the economic
and monetary affairs committee voted in
favor of a clear information regarding
investment products this includes for
example it will become obligatory to
flag the risks involved before any
contract is signed
it is worth bearing in mind that the
investment market in the european union
represents around 10 billion euros
exactly
what